president who says a trade war might not
be a bad thing certainly did nothing to
discourage that concept today President
Trump rolling out some numbers to
justify his position in the face of a
nine-year high in the US trade imbalance
he argues the playing field has not been
close to being even chief White House
correspondent John Robert starts us off
tonight on the North Lawn good evening
John where you were just this morning
good morning to you bill sources tell
Fox News that the decision has been made
and that tomorrow President Trump will
put into effect tariffs on foreign
metals 10% for aluminum 25% for steel
president Trump promoted his plans to
impose punitive tariffs on aluminum and
steel today tweeting that in the last 25
years America has lost more than 55,000
factories six million manufacturing jobs
and accumulated trade deficits of more
than 12 trillion dollars but in the face
of retaliation from America's closest
trading partners press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders said there could be
some carve-outs there are potential
carve outs for Mexico and Canada based
on national security and possibly other
countries as well the pronouncement was
a sharp about-face for the president who
on Friday tweeted tariffs on steel and
aluminum will only come off if new and
fair NAFTA agreement is signed and it
happened as first son-in-law Jared
Kushner led a delegation to meet with
Mexico's president today about NAFTA a
trip he was able to make despite his
degraded security clearance the European
Union has threatened to hit president
Trump politically if he imposes tariffs
the EU says it will strike back with
Paris against US goods like bed linens
chewing tobacco motorcycles cranberries
and orange juice all produced in swing
states the president one who is going to
hit him where it hurts is he prepared to
take the hit the president is prepared
to protect our country that is the
number-one priority he has as president
is to protect our economic and national
security interests tariffs were a big
reason chief economic advisor Gary cone
decided to call it quits the straw that
broke the camel's back according to one
White House official Cohen is a fierce
opponent of tariffs he was also facing
year where the leading economic policy
would be rewriting trade deals he didn't
think should be scrapped the White House
downplayed the notion that talented
people were fleeing the West Wing this
is an intense place as every White House
and it's not abnormal that you would
have people come and go but we're
continuing to do great work the White
House also held open the possibility
Cohen could return he has been a top
choice for a cabinet position when
there's a vacancy they maintain a strong
relationship and are gonna continue that
relationship and certainly continue to
Gary will continue to be an advocate for
the president in a number I'm not
closing the door
president Trump also alternately played
good cop Babcock with China in a tweet
taking aim at China's legacy of
bootlegging morning the u.s. is acting
swiftly on intellectual property theft
we cannot allow this to happen as it has
for many years but at the same time he
revealed a plan to help level the
playing field on trade tweeting China
has been asked to develop a plan for the
year of a 1 billion dollar reduction in
their massive trade deficit with the
United States sources tell Fox News the
president will sign an order
implementing the new tariffs on aluminum
and steel tomorrow afternoon at 3:30
that is a half hour before the stock
market closes and the stock market has
not had much of an appetite for tariffs
lately now we will watch that thank you
John Roberts from the White House